hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
regardez mirel on l'a découvert chez
sophie davant c'est parti et mimi
regarder mais me comme bp voudrait faire
de la pub éventuellement faire du cinéma
oui mais j'ai toujours entendu dire que
pour le cinéma il faut coucher je ne
bouge pas alors le matin moi je suis sur
leur dit mireille les pronos c'est quoi
les pronos les pronostics
un show subi le gap s'est mis au
diapason le pronom le lieu j'ai bien
joué moi je suis là oui je parle en
verlan
ah pardon j'adore le fait hriech le
faire c'est vrai vous parlez pas verlan
laferrière d'accord donc j'imagine le
soin à 12h30 j'adore cyril il via une
méta visé touche pas à mon poste
ah non cyril hanouna et j'ai pas de
doute ce soit
je suis un gang de serbie qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire est que ce nous mener
la danse des sardines on est avec toi
vous êtes un petit plaisir
chanter
[Applaudissements]
dans l'émission today show
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci ltte pas alors
voilà ça fait partie de nos chouchous de
l'année mireille bien sûr et on a
d'autres chouchou est ce que vous
rappelez d'histoire naturelle les
insomniaques bien sûr regard d'histoire
naturelle vous qu'on rentrait de boîte
de nuit jean-michel surtout regarder un
histoire naturelle non c'est plutôt le
jt du meuble